[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALISON WAGONFELD: Hi, everyone.
I'm Alison Wagonfeld
with Google Cloud.
Welcome to Google Cloud
Next, and thank you
to our Google Orchestra
composed of Bay Area Googlers.
We are coming to you live
from our Google Cloud
Campus in Silicon Valley,
where I'm here with Sundar
Pichai and Thomas Kurian.
We have an incredible lineup
over the next three days
with live keynotes, demos,
and Q&A with our leadership,
and over 140 sessions covering
all our Cloud solutions.
Our customers and
partners will share
how they're using Google Cloud
and Google Workspace technology
to tackle their greatest
challenges and opportunities.
We are humbled to support their
work and share their stories.
Thank you for being
here with us, and now,
please, join me in welcoming
Google and Alphabet CEO Sundar
Pichai.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Cloud Next 2021.
We are happy you're here.
Of course, I'd be happier
if you could actually
be here in person.
Don't get me wrong.
Thomas is great
company, but he still
doesn't laugh at
my container jokes.
So while many of us are still
waiting for a return to normal,
it does feel like
we are on our way.
The question is, will
we recognize normal
when we get there?
The pandemic has
sped up digitization
in all aspects of our lives.
It's changed how
we visit a doctor,
how our kids learn
in school, and how
we connect with one another.
And it's made the future
of work our present,
giving us renewed opportunity
to transform our organizations.
From our work with
customers, Thomas and I
have learned there are three
things that position us to be
most helpful to businesses.
First, our Cloud platform.
It's designed to
help enterprises
transform through
digitization, build
on the deep investments
we have made
in technical infrastructure
over the past 23 years.
Looking at our networking and
data center investments alone,
we have the largest network with
the lowest latency of any Cloud
provider.
With our expansions into Warsaw,
Delhi, Melbourne, and Toronto,
this year, we now have 28
regions with plans for 10 more.
And it's all connected
by 19 sub-sea cables.
Our Grace Hopper
transatlantic cable
will be the first to incorporate
novel optical fiber switching.
Second, our enterprise customers
benefit from our consumer scale
and innovation.
We have a deep and
broad consumer ecosystem
of devices and services.
YouTube connects
a global community
of viewers and creators.
Android, Nest,
Assistant, and Maps
are loved by people
around the world.
We have the unique ability to
connect consumer ecosystems
with enterprise ecosystems.
For example, the realistic
voices and language
understanding that
powers Google Assistant
can improve enterprise
customer experiences
and increase satisfaction.
And the underlying
visual technology
that enables Google Lens to
help people shop or learn
about a new flower
in their garden
can help manufacturers
identify defects.
Third, we offer
comprehensive security
that helps organizations,
including ours,
protect what matters.
Security is foundational
to everything we do.
We have a long
history of building it
into every layer of the
computing environment.
We are a pioneer of
zero trust computing
and have deep experience
running this model at scale.
On its own, any one
of these pillars
would be helpful to customers.
Put together, they can
be transformative, which
is the mission of Google Cloud.
We continue to drive innovation
through our products.
Over the past year, we have
had more than 1,500 product
and feature releases.
That's about four a day.
They're all designed to be
helpful from Smart Canvas
and Google Workspace that makes
collaboration richer to new AI
powered industry solutions
and Bit Query Omni for data
analytics across any Cloud.
We've also made significant
partnership announcements.
For example, we teamed up
with global telecom leaders,
such as Ericsson, Nokia, and
T-Systems to deliver 5G edge
and hosted computing solutions.
What I'm most
excited about is how
our strengths in Cloud,
consumer, and security
are helping top
enterprises accelerate
their transformation.
Ford chose Google as their
transformation partner
because of our strength
in consumer and Cloud.
Together, we are innovating in
electrification, connectivity,
and self-driving technologies.
Ford is harnessing Google
Maps to help drivers navigate,
Google Assistant to help
drivers concentrate,
and Google Play to keep
passengers learning
and entertained.
L'Oreal partnered across
Google to build a virtual try
on experience.
They are harnessing
the best AI models,
as well as using YouTube to
build a community of fans,
and Google Shopping to make
it easy to discover and buy
their products.
We are humbled that so
many organizations continue
to put their trust
in Google Cloud,
and we are committed to
helping you solve the biggest
challenges you face.
I'll be back a little later to
talk more about how we do that.
But first, I'll
turn the stage over
to Thomas Kurian,
CEO of Google Cloud
to talk more about our mission.
THOMAS KURIAN:
Thank you, Sundar.
Hello, everyone.
It's a pleasure to be here on
Google's Silicon Valley Campus
today for the moment we all
look forward to all year long,
the opportunity to connect with
you, our customers, partners,
and developers, and to share
all the amazing, exciting stuff
we've been working on.
A special thank you
to all our sponsors,
especially our luminary
sponsors, Accenture, Atos,
Maven Wave, and Deloitte.
Let's first hear from
some of our customers
about the amazing
ways in which they
have accelerated transformation
with Google Cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The pandemic
really did accelerate
the digital wave of change by,
easily, three to five years.
- We transitioned
into all virtual care.
- We're better
positioned to accelerate.
- Fast forward to today,
we have a truly profound,
permanent structural
transformation.
- Now, our team can look at
hundreds of calls in minutes,
instead of weeks.
- Our business has
really been transformed
with the help of Google Cloud.
We have spikes in demand.
We can scale four times
in less than five minutes.
- Schrodinger is transforming
the way scientists
are developing drugs.
The chemical space
is almost infinite.
We can do things we
couldn't do before.
- Can't I just
track my shipment?
We think that we can help solve
that for the supply chain.
- How can we help workers
with artificial intelligence?
- Suddenly, lots of
ideas become interesting.
- We're very excited to develop
our artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
- Access to innovation,
the speed of innovation.
- Seconds, milliseconds
all matter.
- We're rethinking routine
and pioneering simplicity.
- The partnership
with Google Cloud
provides us with technology
that will drive us to be better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
THOMAS KURIAN: Now, it's
not a secret that many
of the biggest and most
innovative technology
companies, leaders, such as
Spotify, Twitter, Shopify,
MercadoLibre,
ShareChat, Dapper Labs,
and so many other
exciting startups
and tech leaders choose
Google Cloud to help them
build, scale, and innovate.
Still, other customers
are transforming
using our purpose-built
industry solutions.
The Home Depot, for
instance, use contact center
AI to reduce customer resolution
time by 91 million minutes.
Procter and Gamble creates
personalized Omnichannel
journeys from over 275
million consumer records.
IKEA retail use
recommendations AI
to increase e-commerce
click through rates by 30%
and increase order value by 2%.
FIH, a Foxconn company,
used visual inspection
to identify defects 10
times more accurately.
Mr. Cooper, a leading
mortgage services provider,
use document AI to process
mortgage documents 400% more
efficiently, and Bank
of New York Mellon
developed a liquidity solution
that predicts nearly 40%
of securities settlement
failures with 90% accuracy.
We're helping many businesses
drive durable innovation
through long term partnerships
with Google's transformation
Cloud.
To help them transform, we
focus on five key themes.
One, are we the best at
understanding and using
data in the industry?
Two, do we have the
industry's leading technology
infrastructure?
Three, are we creating
the best hybrid workplace
for our passionate and
talented employees?
Four, do we know that our data
systems and users are secure
now, and that they will
be secure in the future?
And five, are we
working together
to address the most
important challenges facing
our world today?
We help organizations address
these important questions.
Let's start with
the first question.
Are we the best at understanding
and using data in the industry?
We help organizations
unify their data
across multiple
Clouds and silos,
combining structured
and unstructured data,
and making data every
employees superpower.
Using data analytics
and AI together,
Schrodinger accelerated
clinical drug discovery by 60%,
finding new
breakthroughs faster.
Like many states around
the United States,
the Wisconsin Department
of Workforce Development
confronted a wave of
new unemployment claims.
Using Google's data Cloud, they
clear over 750,000 unemployment
claims, reducing claim times
from weeks to just days
and dispersing over $2 billion
in unemployment benefits.
Walmart is transforming
the experience
for the approximately
220 million shoppers
around the globe who visit
a Walmart store, club,
or e-commerce website each week.
I'm honored today to welcome
Suresh Kumar, Executive Vice
President, Walmart's Global
Chief Technology Officer,
and Chief Development Officer.
SURESH KUMAR: Hi, Thomas,
and hello, everyone.
I'm excited to be
here today to share
about how we at Walmart
are innovating on behalf
of our customers, our
associates, and the role
that our partners,
like you, Google,
have played in our
innovation journey.
Now, I came to Walmart at a
time of incredible digital
transformation.
And jointly, with my team,
created a robust execution plan
to accelerate the transformation
across three areas,
building great
customer experiences,
optimizing our business,
and modernizing our platform
and our infrastructure.
Each of these three priorities
are individually important.
But when you bring them together
at the scale of a business,
like Walmart, it has
a massive impact.
If you move with speed,
you can completely
transform global operations
and disrupt entire industries.
Some of our most data intensive,
our critical decisioning
process are getting the
big credit treatment.
Through this, not only are
we seeing significant savings
that will continue as we
migrate more and more data over.
We are also seeing the
ability to use the data
in interesting ways, including
enabling analytics at scale
and turning data into
actionable insights.
From a data migration
to BigQuery standpoint,
97% of the tables used
for data warehouse
have already migrated to the
Cloud, and 30% of the big data
have been migrated with
plans to almost double that
by the end of this fiscal year.
And the cherry on the
top is that BigQuery
has allowed us to integrate
with pretty much any data
visualization tool and analytics
tool that's out there, thereby,
improving our processing
time by 23% and, of course,
needless to say, a much
better user experience.
Using BigQuery has had a
direct impact on our business.
An excellent example
is our ability
to close our financial books
in three days, instead of five
days, and that's
a pretty big deal.
Leveraging our
Cloud has enabled us
to unleash the potential of
AI across our entire business.
This goes from predicting demand
to managing in stock levels
to optimizing supply
chain to freeing up
time for our associates
to serve our customers.
As one example, express deliver,
which is our two-hour delivery
service, which we
launched last year,
actively uses AI
behind the scenes
as the customer is
creating their order.
Multiple algorithms
work in unison
to optimize the deliveries
out and determine
if the customer is eligible
for express delivery.
We are building our own
AI and ML capabilities
to power multiple
areas of our business,
including classification,
natural language processing,
forecasting, regression,
computer vision, predictions,
process automations,
and a whole lot more.
So to wrap up, I'm really
excited about the opportunity
Walmart has to drive
innovation and to further
disrupt the retail industry.
I hope you agree that
our work together
is making a huge difference
for our customers
and our associates.
Thank you for having me.
THOMAS KURIAN:
Thank you, Suresh.
You know, tens of thousands
of incredible organizations,
like Walmart, choose Google's
data Cloud for four reasons.
First, Google's data Cloud is
the most complete and unified
data and AI platform to help you
manage every stage of the data
lifecycle from running
operational transactions
to developing
analytical applications.
We help customers unify
data lakes and warehouses,
as data lake houses,
to reduce complexity
and to combine structured
and unstructured data.
Built in data science
and AI with support
from MapReduce, Park, and Presto
enables continuous learning
and experimentation.
And we support
real time streaming
that natively uses Open Source
standards, like Beam and Flink.
Google's data Cloud is also
unmatched for speed, scale,
security, and reliability.
BigQuery, one of the most
successful and beloved data
warehouse solutions with its
unique serverless approach
during a typical week
helps more than 3,000
different organizations
analyze more than 200 petabytes
of data, and
thousands of customers
use Dataproc to run Spark
and Hadoop clusters easily.
Spanner, a fully managed
relational database
with unlimited scale and
multi-zone and multi-region
consistency serves more than
one billion requests per second
and provides a 59 SLA.
Google data Cloud's
Vertex AI offers the AI
pioneered at Google
Research and Deepmind.
So that every data scientist
and ML engineer can now
build, deploy, and
scale AI models
faster and with 80%
less code using AI
the same way Google does.
For instance, GE Appliances, an
appliance manufacturing leader
for more than a century is
using Google Cloud, including
AI at the Edge, to build
innovative digital products
with over-the-air updates.
Finally, Google's data Cloud
is more open standards based.
You can choose from Postgres,
MySQL, Redis, MongoDB,
or migrate from
Oracle or SQL server.
And we have strategic
partners with leading data
driven applications.
For instance, C3 AI has
made its entire lineup
of AI based applications
available on Google Cloud.
Our customers can analyze,
govern, and visualize data
from many databases and storage
system on Google or other
clouds, including all of
Google's databases, Google
Sheets, and BigQuery,
using Looker,
our premier BI and embedded
analytics solution.
You know, today, we're
thrilled and excited
to announce that we'll
be integrating Tableau,
a leader in data
visualization with Looker,
Google Sheets, and BigQuery.
Tableau customers will
soon be able to use
Looker's semantic model,
enabling new levels of data
governance and access to data.
Let's take a look at this.
Alex, over to you.
ALEKSANDRA ALEKSIC:
Thank you, Thomas.
In this demo, we're going to
show you how you can seamlessly
use Looker and Tableau
together to answer
your critical
business questions.
Let's say, I work at
an e-commerce company,
and our Looker model
provides a consistent view
across the organization for
our most important business
metrics.
Here, for example, you
can see the definition
for gross margin.
Our Looker dashboard is based
on that same semantic model.
Since it provides trusted
insights at a glance,
I can immediately see
that sales are up.
However, did I miss anything?
Let's find out.
Say, I'm more comfortable
working in spreadsheets.
I can now take advantage of the
new integration between Looker
and Google Sheets.
With a couple of clicks, I
have access to my governed
and trusted Looker
data and Sheets,
and I can easily connect
to my data models.
To understand which factors
are impacting sales,
I'll drag and drop feeds from
my model into a pivot table
to break out sales by
category over time.
Since it's pulling
from Looker, I
can trust that all the data
definitions are consistent.
I can use familiar Sheets
formulas and formatting
to get insights faster
and understand how
specific products are selling.
We see a notable downward
trend, month over month,
for activewear.
I want to share these
findings with my marketing
team who's using Tableau.
Now, I can use the new
Tableau and Looker integration
to combine data from my Looker
data model with marketing data
to build a more comprehensive
view of my business.
Next, I'm going to
plot sales by category
and then add marketing
spend to the view.
Tableau makes it easy for me
to drill down on relevant data.
Now, I can see that
social marketing spend
was significantly
lower for activewear,
and this is why there's a
downward trend in activewear
sales.
I'm going to publish this
result on Tableau Online
and tag my marketing team,
so they can take action.
Leveraging integrations between
Tableau, Sheets, and Looker
allows our teams to build
powerful visualizations
using trusted data.
We can then share
these visualizations
throughout our organization
to drive informed decisions,
action, and impact.
Back over to you, Thomas.
THOMAS KURIAN: Thank you, Alex.
The second question
customers ask,
do we have industry leading
technology infrastructure?
We're experiencing
great momentum
with our open
infrastructure Cloud.
Many of the most demanding
and technically advanced
customers in the world
disproportionately choose us.
Take, for example, leading
media companies and streaming
services, such as
Univision and Globo,
the largest media
group in Latin America.
They use our high performance
networking, computing,
and storage to broadcast
media, including
live events, such as the
recent Tokyo Olympics.
Leading telecommunications
companies
are also choosing Google Cloud.
Reliance GIO, the world's
second largest mobile carrier,
is automating its 5G network.
Vodafone is processing
over a billion network
events each day.
AT&T is delivering new
multi-access edge computing
solutions, and Tellus
is migrating critical IT
and network workloads
all to Google Cloud.
You know, leading data
management companies, including
Databricks, Redis, Cockroach
Labs, Couchbase, Elastic,
InfluxData, MariaDB,
MongoDB, Neo4j,
and Single Store are all
growing faster on Google Cloud
than on any other Cloud.
And they love our
storage scalability
and advanced infrastructure.
MongoDB, for instance,
has more net new customers
via Google Cloud Marketplace
than on any other Cloud.
Leading cybersecurity companies,
such as Palo Alto Networks,
Exabeam, [? FY ?] Shape,
Splunk, Broadcom, and ForgeRock
are also choosing Google
Cloud for its performance,
global scale, and
underlying security.
Customers are migrating and
transforming SAP and VMware
workloads to Google Cloud.
In just the last year, we've
added three times the number
of SAP customers as the prior
year, and we're accelerating.
PayPal, for instance, has an
SAP HANA scale out system,
supporting 40 million
business transactions daily,
200 billion records
touched in just 30 seconds.
Mitel in Canada migrated over
1,000 VMware virtual machines
in less than 90 days to
Google Cloud VMware Engine.
[? Needless, ?] an API Platform
company, chose our Tau Virtual
Machines along with Google
Kubernetes Engine as they
saw over 40% better
price performance
than in a competitor.
Customers choose our
open Cloud infrastructure
for three main reasons.
First, we make your path
to migrate and modernize
using Cloud easy with
migration tools, new serverless
and container capabilities,
and manage services
as your developers
spend more time building
experiences that
your customers love.
Second, we offer
transformative capabilities
with cutting edge
performance and security.
And our network
offers three times
the throughput of
other Cloud providers.
Third, we remain and were
the very first and only Cloud
provider with a clear
multi-Cloud strategy.
We provide you with a
consistent developer experience
built in Open Source to write
once and deploy anywhere.
Many customers, like Plaid,
a financial services leader,
use Anthos to deploy, operate,
and manage applications
across multiple clouds.
Recently, we introduced
Anthos for virtual machines,
standardizing the
way that you manage
applications across both
virtual machines and containers.
For multi-Cloud
data, BigQuery Omni
lets customers analyze data
across Google Cloud, AWS,
and Azure.
With it, Johnson and
Johnson, for instance,
was able to combine data
in Google Cloud and AWS S3,
using BigQuery without
needing to migrate data.
Customers also want
to expand where
they use Google Cloud, whether
in their private data centers
or out on the edge.
For instance, some workloads
cannot move to the public Cloud
entirely due to the need for
large amounts of local data
processing, extremely low
latency, or strict regulations.
To solve these challenges,
we're announcing
today, Google Distributed
Cloud, a portfolio of hardware
and software solutions that
extend our infrastructure
to the edge, and even
into your own data center.
To tell you more about
it, please, welcome
Ines from our Google Cloud
Distributed Cloud team.
INES ENVID: Thank you, Thomas.
Google Distributed
Cloud is a set
of fully managed
services running
on Google [INAUDIBLE] hardware.
Based on open API
and built on Anthos,
it gives customers greater
deployment flexibility
and ensures more
consistent operations
across hybrid and
multi-cloud environments
more than any other
Cloud provider.
There are four
deployment scenarios,
depending on your
specific needs.
Google's network edge,
this allows customers
to leverage over
140 network edge
locations around the world.
Operator edge, this
scenario is designed
to accommodate emerging
services and applications
with a stringent latency
and reliability requirements
for a specific operator.
Customer edge, this
scenario supports
customer on edge locations,
such as retail stores, factory
floors, or branch offices,
which require localized compute
and processes.
And finally, customer
data centers.
This deployment option
is specific to customer
own data centers
and call facilities.
Google Distributed Cloud
also includes a hosted mode
to run sensitive workloads
and address data, sovereignty,
security, and
privacy requirements.
It does not require connectivity
to Google Cloud at any time
to manage infrastructure,
services, APIs, or tooling.
You have the choice
to manage it yourself
or host through a
designated trusted partner.
Back to you, Thomas.
THOMAS KURIAN: Thank you, Ines.
Partners, like HPE,
Dell, Cisco, and NetApp,
are key as we deploy Google
Distributed Cloud globally
on best in class hardware.
I'm pleased to announce the
expansion of our partnership
with Network Appliance
in two important ways.
First, NetApp is
our primary partner,
supporting Google's Distributed
Cloud Storage infrastructure.
Second, for customers using
Google Cloud VMware Engine,
they now have preview access
for NetApp Cloud volumes.
We are the only hyperscaler
to provide customers
with this choice.
Deep partnerships with
T-Systems and Tellus
have also enabled us to address
the evolving sovereignty
requirements for
Cloud technology
in Germany and France.
The next question we hear is,
how can we provide the best
environment to help
employees create and innovate
together, especially
in a hybrid workplace?
You know, hybrid is
redefining how we all work,
making it less
about where we work,
but more about the
quality of our experience.
Studies estimate that
more than 48% of employees
will work remotely post-COVID.
Google Workspace is
the best platform
for hybrid work with simple,
powerful, and secure tools
to help people communicate and
collaborate with one another,
no matter where they are.
We introduce Smart Canvas to
help content creators remove
friction from
workflows and enable
teams to stay connected
outside of meetings
to foster well-being and
reduce video call fatigue.
We made communication
and collaboration
completely seamless.
For instance, users can
easily present and collaborate
in meetings, create meeting
notes from their calendar,
present and meet directly
from doc sheets of slides,
and collaborate directly
from chat and spaces.
We optimize collaboration
from all mobile devices
to provide great experiences for
frontline workers who make up
80% of the global workforce.
One of America's largest
hospital systems,
CommonSpirit Health, is
advancing its mission
during the pandemic by
making its frontline doctors
and nurses productive
at Google Workspace.
Since hybrid work has
removed the notion
for physical location for
work, Google Workspace
created Spaces, a unified,
digital location for work.
Today, more than
three billion users
move securely and seamlessly
between Mail, Chat, Audio,
Video, and now, Spaces.
And you, too, can choose among
the over 5,300 public apps
in our marketplace,
and you can also
add thousands of private apps
to enhance your workspace.
And I want to step
aside for just a minute
and tell you about a hidden
secret in our portfolio
of products, AppSheet,
our no code platform that
makes it easy for everyone, not
just professional developers
to build amazing
apps and workflows.
For instance, property
managers at car Ford properties
use the AppSheet to
build a mobile app
to log, track, and resolve
problems with headquarters,
replacing a multi-step
manual process.
We're also partnering
with Citrix,
because employees sometimes need
access to Windows and Mac OS
applications and desktops
directly served from the Cloud.
We're expanding our
partnership with Citrix
today to deliver an integrated
desktop as a service solution
purpose built on Google Cloud.
Now, customers ask us, do we
know that our data systems
and users are
secure, and how do we
keep them secure in the future?
As more digital users access
more data from more locations,
the risk of cybersecurity
breaches is accelerating.
By pioneering new
approaches to security,
Google keeps more
people safe online
than anyone else in the world.
Take, for instance, JetBlue.
It's keeping its system
secure, protecting
the data of all its travelers,
and modernizing its security
operations using Chronicle
to detect threats
across petabytes of
security telemetry
and eliminating
data blind spots.
Commerzbank, one of
Germany's largest banks
is using a new certificate
authority service
to verify machine and
workload identity,
improving security, simplifying
operations, eliminating
entire classes of threats.
Secure by default
drives customers
to choose Google Cloud.
First, we've
implemented zero trust
at the core of our services
and our operations,
enabling you to trust nothing.
Second, we've built Cloud scale
threat detection and response,
allowing you to
detect everything.
And third, we know it's
not just about tools.
We provide the
advisory services you
need to transform
security operations.
We keep customers safe with
BeyondCorp Enterprise, which
enables zero trust access
for all your users.
Today, we're
expanding BeyondCorp
to all your applications, modern
and legacy, web and desktop,
and even to production
environments.
We keep customers safe by
eliminating software supply
chain vulnerabilities.
Over the past two decades,
we pioneered an approach
to secure our own
software supply chain.
We are now making
that technology
available through the SLSA open
source framework and as managed
services in our Cloud to help
you secure your own software
supply chain.
We keep customers safe by
integrating Chronicle's threat
detection capability with
our Security Command Center,
allowing you to respond
faster to potential risks.
And we keep customers safe by
bringing our security expertise
to you with our Google
Cybersecurity Action Team,
a team of our leading
security experts
who can help shape your
security transformation
from your very
first implementation
through responding
to a major incident
and engineering new
solutions as needs change.
Finally, we continue to
expand our security ecosystem
with companies, like Fortinet,
Palo Alto Networks, Tellus,
and so many more.
Today, I'd like to
welcome your new security
partner, Cybereason, with
whom we are collaborating
to deliver a new extended
detection and response
offering.
That will combine
Chronicle's capability
with Cybereasons mal ops engine
for faster, easier threat
detection and response.
Our products, our new
Cybersecurity Action Team,
and our partnerships
all make the world safer
from cyber threats.
To talk more about how we help
keep each and every one of you
secure and how we're
addressing some
of the most important
challenges facing our world,
I'd like to invite Sundar back.
Thank you.
SUNDAR PICHAI:
Thank you, Thomas.
Security is top of mind for
businesses of all sizes,
as well as the public sector.
And despite the progress that
has been made in cybersecurity,
large scale breaches
continue to make headlines.
That's why, in August,
Google announced
we will invest $10 billion
over the next five years
to strengthen cybersecurity.
That includes expanding
zero trust programs,
helping secure the
software supply chain,
and enhancing
open-source security.
A new challenge is
keeping collaboration
secure and private as we move
to hybrid work environments.
To help, We are introducing
a new work safer program.
It provides the highest level
of security for your email,
meetings, messaging, and
more, and brings together
Google Workspace with Titan
Security Keys, BeyondCorp,
and other secure technologies,
products, and partners.
Now, every kind of
organization in business
can access the same
security protections
that make work safer at Google.
Security is an issue
that affects us all,
and this brings us to the
last question Thomas posed.
Are we addressing the
most important challenges
facing our world?
Climate change is one of
the most profound challenges
we face.
It'll take all of us working
together to solve it.
Sustainability has been
a core value for us
for more than two decades.
Google has been carbon
neutral since 2007,
and we've matched our operations
with 100% renewable energy
over four consecutive years.
Last year, we set out to make
our third decade of climate
action our biggest yet.
That Included a bold commitment
to operate on 24/7 carbon
free energy across our offices
and data centers by 2030.
And last week, we
announced new ways
we are helping
one billion people
make more sustainable choices.
When it comes to
enterprises, one
of the most important
sustainability choices
is where to run your technology.
IDC predicts Cloud migrations
over the next four years
could reduce carbon emissions
by over one billion metric tons
or the equivalent of
removing 200 million cars
off the road for a year.
We are proud that Google
Cloud is the cleanest Cloud
in the industry.
Earlier this year, we
introduced a way for customers
to choose the cleanest regions
to run their workloads.
Today, we are
expanding our portfolio
of solutions and partnerships
to help reduce your carbon
footprint.
First, we have focused on
giving you greater transparency
around carbon emissions data.
We are announcing Carbon
Footprint, a new service
to measure, track, and
report the gross carbon
emissions associated with
your Google Cloud usage.
Having this data at your
fingertips is really important,
and we know that many
customers track sustainability
data in other places.
That's why I'm happy to announce
that Google Cloud emission
data will integrate directly
into Salesforce sustainability
Cloud.
We also want to give you the
tools to act on the data.
So today, we are
introducing a new tool
that will alert you when
you have idle workloads
and make recommendations
to reduce carbon emissions.
It's all part of
our goal to help
make your Cloud transformation
secure, and sustainable,
and solve for what's next.
So on behalf of
Thomas and myself,
let me thank you, once
again, for trusting
us to be a partner with
you on this journey.
And we hope you enjoy
the next three days.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]